what do you think women want in men
exactly the opposite of what they're
saying they want right now
honestly I there's a there seems to be a
culture of women saying you know I want
this absolutely perfect Prince Charming
who dotes on me all the time and is
super emotional and is constantly
updating me on his feelings and then
they show their boyfriend and it's like
this masculine provider protector who is
you know constantly there for you but
handles problems so I think that's what
women actually want and what they
gravitate towards but what comes out of
the mouth can be a little different
welcome to episode 154 of my podcast I'm
Michaela Peterson in this episode I
spoke with Amala epinobi
Amala is a social media personality and
the host of prageru's show Unapologetic
with Amela raised in a far left activist
household Amala embodies a trend that
many young people are participating in
moving from the political left to the
right
ammo and I discussed her previous
activism which was really interesting
politics how she changed her mind and
why when she moved from the left to the
right what it's like working for prageru
online negativity she experiences and
more this episode is sponsored by rabbit
air as you guys may know I've moved from
the Luscious Green State of Tennessee to
Miami to avoid allergies mainly I liked
Nashville Nashville is super cute but I
was allergic to it basically year round
I have really severe seasonal allergies
and allergies to everything else really
and I used to have a hard time getting
quality deep sleep it turns out it was
due to allergic reactions at night so in
Tennessee that was pollen and in Toronto
it was dust or down I have three rabbit
air purifiers seen right there
my old one which is in my living room
has my lion logo on it which I think is
hilarious and my husband hates but this
new air purifier from rabbit air
is pretty crispy looking I think
everyone should have air filters at
least in their bedrooms and kids
bedrooms not only do rabbit airs air
purifiers work well but they have a
super clean very attractive look they're
very quiet as you can hear
and they look great in rooms more than
anything though the air purifier that I
got from average air changed the way I
sleep their A3 model for example won the
world's most prestigious Red Dot design
award thanks to its stylish design and
the advanced filtration technology that
targets Airborne allergens particles and
odors effectively even if you have no
issues sleeping we still breathe in
nearly 2 000 gallons of air a day if
you're breathing in air that isn't clean
that can lead to a host of problems
least of all fatigue so please do
yourself a favor and visit rabbitair.com
today to see their models or call them
24 7 to speak to a rapid air consultant
that's
r-a-b-b-i-t-a-i-r.com for access to the
best air purifiers you'll find anywhere
I hope you enjoy this episode
amla epinobi welcome to my podcast
it's good to be here thank you for
having me
yeah this is gonna be fun I've been I've
been seeing you out and about on the
internet so I'm glad that we can finally
talk yeah that's awesome yeah I sort of
just stumbled into the world of the
internet making these videos and now
people like reach out to me and they're
like I see your face everywhere so it's
just been a really Wild Ride
that's fun okay before we get started
can you give a brief background about
who you are and what it is you do sure
yeah my name is amla bonobi I am 21
years old and I currently work at
prageru as a personality which basically
means that I I make uh social content I
do political commentary about things
that are happening day in and day out
and I got here because I was raised in a
really far left-leaning household and
was what I like to call indoctrinated
from a pretty young age and wanted to be
an activist and eventually through my
experience working with the political
left sort of woke up and realized oh
well maybe I don't quite align with
these views and when I started getting
on the Internet to talk about that that
of course shook the shook the space a
little bit
wow okay there's a lot to unpack there
so yeah how does how does your family
feel about you working with prageru
uh so for the most part my family is
really supportive of it it was a moment
where when I started talking about what
I was doing and making these videos
online there was a rocky road
particularly with my mom because I was
raised by a single mother and she works
for the political left so she was not
really happy about the whole transition
that I went through
yeah okay that's that's fair
um so what did your act you said you
actually did activism did you have
activist days yes so from a really young
age I was super involved in politics
really on the social end of things
talking about uh
racism environmental racism women's
Reproductive Rights and feminism and all
that fun stuff because that's what my
mom did for a living she was fundraising
for people who were organizing and and
working on different amendments and
getting bills passed so I was constantly
going to work with her as a child and I
would volunteer help them make signs
whenever they were going to do a new
protest and when I graduated high school
I thought well there's higher education
is not that important to me right now I
need to go and pursue activism because
nothing's going to happen if I don't
change the world myself and I ended up
getting a position at my mom's
organization as a youth organizer which
essentially just had me traveling around
to different middle schools and high
schools where I grew up and finding
other young people and making them into
activists as well
interesting okay I I mean there's
something to that to being told that you
have the ability to change the world
like oh absolutely that that doesn't
seem super unhealthy it's just unhealthy
I guess if you end up pushing things you
don't believe in right yeah and I think
it's it's something that I think is
different where I've changed is I'm no
longer in this pool of oh I'm trying to
transform the world and constantly
change things and create a new Society
or whatever the case may be I'm more so
trying to look from the view of
understanding the world and
understanding my place in it and and
what the meaning or or purpose of my
life is as opposed to just constantly
pushing things on other people as I was
doing before
okay okay so what changed and when did
that change for you man so for me it
changed about three years ago I was I
was 17 turning 18 at the time and I was
working for this organization nine to
five every day and a lot of my job was
revolving around misery I was sort of
waking up every day and looking for the
Injustice in the world as you can
imagine yeah looking for racism and
sexism and misogyny and looking for
areas where people were oppressed and
trying to educate other young people
about that and in a lot of ways it
retrospectively I realized that I was
kind of stealing hope and optimism away
from a lot of young people in my life
and I think that reflected in my
attitude whether or not I was conscious
of it or not and that mixed with going
into work every day and recognizing
intolerance among the people that I was
working with really pushed me so yeah
I'm biracial I was I was raised by a
white family so I would go into work
every day and hear about how whiteness
is evil people and white people have
controlled the conversation for too long
and we need to start pushing them out of
our spaces and making them into allies
and then I would go home to my white
family who had took care of me my entire
life and I I couldn't see the racism
that everybody was talking about uh and
and that really broke down the walls of
my ideology uh from that from that
moment
okay uh how did you end up working with
prageru and when did that happen how
long have you been with them I've only
been with them for a little over a year
now and it started because I made videos
on Tick Tock I left the organization
that I was working for and for about a
year and a half did nothing but just
research because I had found all these
issues where I was deciding to change my
mind and open up a little bit more and I
thought well what else could I possibly
be wrong about or what else would I have
a different right have you experienced
that yeah mine was mine was okay I'll
I'll give you a bit of background
because my mind was different
um I was very ill I had an autoimmune
disorder and I was like put into the
medical system that's how I put it
anyway when I was seven and I was in the
hospital all the time and when I was 20
three it was when I was 23 so a bit
older than you but um I ended up putting
myself into remission with diet with a
paleo diet at the beginning and all my
health symptoms went away and I was on
like eight medications I was
unbelievably ill and that happened and I
thought
I had no idea that that was possible I
didn't know that was possible I was told
that wasn't possible and then I had the
same kind of experience where I started
looking around being like I so firmly
believed this and I was so wrong that
what if I'm wrong about a whole bunch of
other things and I'm conducting my life
in a way like based on lies and so my
belief in everything disappeared for a
while yeah I went through that the same
exact thing as you and I'm wondering if
you experienced this where when you
started to recognize that you might have
been wrong or might have had a different
perception you wanted to hold on to what
you believe to and and I wanted to hold
on and wanted to believe everything that
I had thought my whole life where it was
kind of hard to open up and go in and
look at new things did that happen to
you at all
I mean yeah I think what I mean I had a
difficult time like the way I got to
diet was through Reading scientific
papers and that slowly led me to diet
and it hurt it definitely hurt when I
had that switch it was like I was wrong
there was like I would say there was
some physical pain there letting go of
some of those beliefs so if that's what
you mean it wasn't easy it wasn't just
like a switch it was it broke me for a
number of years
it wasn't a quick recovery it was like I
was so kind of uh I felt arrogant that's
how I felt I was like I was so pot sure
about myself and like how could I have
been that sure and so wrong and I hope I
never make that mistake again the same
and it's like it's part of it's part of
growing up too I was so confident as a
young person like I was going out and
doing speeches and organizing students
and like being the person to lead that
now I look back at myself and go oh my
gosh you were you had so much audacity
for such a young person who truly didn't
know anything at the time and then when
you realize you don't know anything
you're like wow I just dedicated all
this time all this energy to something
that I thought was just absolutely true
and then it's not and it's it's
devastating in a way but then you seek
some fulfillment out of learning what is
what is actually true or at least trying
to find what is actually true
well then that's good and you're
obviously going about that the right way
because there are lots of people who
kind of realize that they're wrong about
something and then rather than pursuing
the truth they just go oh well never
mind I'm just going to double down on
what I believe even if it's not true
because it hurts to change what you
believe right a hundred percent and when
I had gone into the rabbit hole of of
this whole transition and of actually
finding out where I where I laid on
things I entered the journey with the
intent of doubling down on what I
believed and I had a particular instance
where I was pulled over by a police
officer and through my younger years in
life I had obviously always followed the
news and things that my mother and her
organization had shown me and it was
stuff like Tamir rice and Michael Brown
and Eric Garner and philando Castile
like I watched that video with my own
eyes so I had already had this
preconceived notion that if I had ever
had an encounter with a police officer
it was going to go poorly and when the
moment came to fruition and I saw the
lights and this guy walks up to my car I
started freaking out and I had never had
such a visceral response I mean just
like crying shaking remembering to like
turn your camera on put your hands on
Ten and two and this white male cop
walked up which was my worst nightmare
at the time and he just recognized
something and said you know I'm not here
to hurt you at all you were just driving
a little too fast yeah it was just like
a beautiful moment and I've never seen
that man again he'll never know exactly
what he did for me but that moment
crushed something in me so I went to the
internet and I was like no there's no
way that there's good police in America
I need to look into this I need to
double down on what I believe and I
found the opposite so that's what
sparked it for me
wow that's wild yeah in retrospect I had
a lot of just like crazy weird moments
that made me question where I was and
who I was
yeah okay well fair enough
um so what was so did prageru find you
on Tick Tock through the tick tocks yeah
so I started making videos on the
internet just as a hobby just saying
like hey I'm a conservative I believe
this this and that and this was my old
self and the videos just slowly started
picking up traction and I think I had a
video that all of a sudden just got 10
million views on the platform wow yeah
it was it was wild and and it it blew up
and I was getting all this hate and all
this support and one of the people
working here at Prager you reached out
to me and was like hey I'd love to just
get on a call with you to discuss your
story and I I hopped on this call and
told her my story and she said well
we're doing a casting call to find the
next will wit and yeah we're very
similar as you can probably see and
she's like we'd love to bring you out to
LA to tell your story so I flew out and
did a video called stories of us where I
told it and went over everything and
then they offered me a job and I thought
you know what I'm young whatever I
should take this opportunity so I within
a span of like three weeks moved out
here yeah wow that's awesome thank you
so what what's it like are you I mean I
suppose they're there watching you so
you can't really tell me but what's it
like where are you enjoying are you
having a good time it's I am having a
good time and I imagine it's it's
similar to to what you're doing like you
have this massive platform that's just
been thrown in your lap a little bit
which can be stressful and overwhelming
but you have so much Freedom about what
you talk about and what you say and I
get to just re be really open uh about
the things that I'm learning and and
going through and that's the wonderful
thing about it I think the only downside
is I often feel an immense amount of
pressure to just stay on top of
everything that's happening all the time
which I'm sure you feel too and to
constantly just have something to say
about everything that's happening in the
world but other than that there's so
much Freedom involved with this job
that's nice uh that's that's great
that's great that's good to hear that
doesn't sound stifling either no what's
an average day look like for you
average J I sort of get up uh start
looking at what everybody's talking
about in the news and looking at all the
differing perspectives on it and just
sort of getting a grasp on on what
people think and feel and I will make
like micro content for social media on
the biggest trending stories and those
are the little reels and shorts that
everybody sees and then I start working
on my Daily Show which I do an hour
every single day talking about wow uh
any given topic yeah and I'll write out
the different stories for that start
bullet pointing my perspective and
giving voice to people who oppose what I
have to say and and then we go live at
three o'clock and do that for everybody
wow that's really fun that's it every
day every day quite a bit of work yeah
yeah so you must be pretty involved in
what's going on I'm not I'm really
honestly no I keep hopping on this
podcast and they're like remember
there's the don't say gay bill I didn't
hear about it for a month oh look at you
yeah I've been like like I don't know
Elon buying Twitter I was on top of that
is that something that's been about it
are you just like I I'm actively trying
to stay away from this because it's not
something that's good for my life or is
it just something that you don't
particularly take interest in
um I've just been busy like I do um I
have my podcast but I don't spend very
much hopefully I'm going to spend more
time on the podcast because I used to
put episodes out twice a week that was
better but I got so busy with uh work
for my dad and we're building a new
platform and
so I have haven't been up to date I
think it's been that and then moving all
over the place now I can only imagine
how busy it must be especially with all
the family work you guys are like
building an empire and it's so it's so
needed I can imagine it's
very thin but it's fun I think when I
settle down in Miami then I'll put
episodes twice a week and I'll be more
on top of oh you're gonna have so much
fun enjoy it
yeah you're gonna do so well in Miami
too Florida is the best and I miss it so
much did you did you move from Florida
where in Florida were you yeah I was in
Central Florida near Orlando and about a
little over a year ago I moved out here
to La which was just massive culture
shock super change from like Freedom
states to California which was just so
different for me
yeah no every time I go to California
I'm like yeah nah just give it a few
more years now I always wanted to move
to LA I wanted to move to LA since I was
little from California and then a couple
years ago I was like maybe not so much
oh me too I have these wild expectations
of what La was actually going to be and
then I got here and it by no means was
the reality yeah yeah okay I'm gonna go
through I've got a whole list of
questions for you okay cool
um but okay let's start with
now let's start with this just to finish
up what we were talking about did your
kind of uh I wouldn't say conversion but
switching beliefs uh did you end up
losing a lot of friends or were you able
to kind of explain the transition to
people
it's interesting because I
a wide variety of friends at the time
and my conservative friends who were
friends with me somehow during my crazy
radical period when I was contesting
everything they had to say all the time
they stuck around and just cheered me on
and were just happy to see that I was
evolving and getting more open to things
it was my Progressive friends who dipped
out and they did so silently which was
the really interesting thing for me like
I had been talking to them on a daily
basis and uh on the side was just
posting these social media videos and uh
promoting that and talking about the the
journey that I was going through and
just slowly but surely they stopped
messaging me I and then I was blocked
and then it was just absolutely no
contact with no explanation which I can
only ascribe to them seeing those videos
and not being happy with what I had to
say because it was sort of this unspoken
reality that we were experiencing where
they just wouldn't bring up politics
with me anymore and
yeah it was it was rougher a little bit
there but then I just recognize you know
those people are not true friends if
they can't stick around when you have a
differing viewpoint
yeah yeah okay okay okay so then on to
my list of questions okay
you have a lot of thoughts on only fans
so I do what are what are some of the
first things that come come to mind
about only fans the first thing that
comes to mind for me is you know if
you're a grown woman and that's
something that you want to do by all
means I do not want to infringe on
people's right to go and do that where I
took issue with that platform in
particular was being on social media and
seeing it pushed so hard for young women
saying that this is uh not only is this
a career alternative but this is
something that's going to make you
hundreds of thousands if not millions of
dollars which is a lie for the most part
of course if you're one of their top
creators that's the money you're gonna
get but I was just scrolling through
social media and of course they curate
these Pages for you based on your
demographics and your age and what they
think you're gonna like or at least be
susceptible to and it was all of these
young women saying you know if you need
a sign to go beyond only fans and sell
your pictures yeah here's my bank
account and I make eighty thousand
dollars a month doing this and I saw
just all these young girls I'm talking
like 13 14 15. commenting well as soon
as I turn 18 this is what I'm gonna do I
can't wait like who needs to go to
school who needs to pursue a career when
you can just do this is your career and
that I just think culturally is probably
a No-No for for our future I would
imagine it's not gonna not gonna look up
yeah yeah I think the issue I've had
with that is
people play it off as if it's not as if
it's fine right they're like I'll do
this for a while it's fine like maybe
things change maybe you drop it later
but like you do that kind of thing and
you're not going to feel good about
yourself right and I I don't and I
honestly don't think I believe that
there are people maybe there's the very
rare individual that does that and is
like yeah I'm fine it's fine but I don't
think that makes people feel good about
themselves and I think like saying that
it's fine it is a lie I completely agree
with you I think it's a veneer that they
put on I think money Shields that a
little bit too yeah I was looking into
it it was like the average uh income
that you make from only fans is somebody
just starting out it's like 180 a month
yeah you're getting all of these young
women to go like oh yeah I'm gonna make
so much money here's my pictures and you
never get to take that back and you have
to think that even the women who are
super successful have to be experiencing
some form of like psychological trauma
walking around and not knowing who has
seen you naked or who has just got to
experience your body in a way that is so
intimate and I yeah I'm just with you on
that one I think it's a total veneer of
people saying this is positive and I
don't mind it at all yeah and then like
you said they prey on really young
people so at like 17 or 18 or 19 or 20
21 even I think like I'd say probably
anything under 23 uh that that idea of
having money especially when you don't
have any so like if you're in University
or something you're like I don't have
you know I have money barely to cover
groceries and that's about it then it's
like this is easy like I'm already kind
of doing it on Instagram just to go a
little bit further dude on only fans but
then you know like I said these
advertising agencies that advertise only
fans so basically only fans
um offer it as an alternative and it's
not something that's going to make you
feel good once you can think more
properly and say yeah it is legitimately
just a massive massive trick and I can
understand why young people fall for it
like when I was in high school I would
always joke about you know oh when I
graduate I'm just going to be a stripper
and that's what's going to pay for my
college yeah exactly I don't like to
joke people have I had that as well some
of my friends be so much easier
stripping yeah yeah and do you think
that you think that and because but it's
not at all it really isn't and it's not
going to pay off your house it's not
going to pay off your college but I
could see like if you're a young person
growing up in this climate right now and
you're looking at like how expensive
higher education is if you are not
particularly happy with the minimum wage
if you're looking at how devastatingly
difficult it can be to buy a house how
you'd be like oh I'll just sell my body
for a few years and then we'll forget
about that and move on but you don't
move on that's the thing
yeah and you don't forget about it no
and I just imagine like you you do only
fans and then like 15 years later you're
sending your kid to school and the other
kids find out that your mom has naked
pictures on the internet just I can only
imagine all the horrible ways that it
could go wrong yeah there are a lot of
them there are so many
uh
okay
I have to be very careful about some of
these questions okay no worries
okay let's cover I haven't actually
talked about this on my podcast yet the
Amber Heard Johnny Depp trial did you
stay up to date on it and what do you
think about the outcomes I didn't watch
the the trial in its entirety but it did
keep up with sort of the ins and outs
who was testifying what was happening
and just the general pulse of the entire
situation and my view I'm very happy
with the verdict that they got on this
of saying that she did to fame him and
it's an interesting thing I I wonder if
this sort of trial is just something
that was a car crash that people
couldn't look away from and that's why
they're so interested or if it's
actually going to change the culture
around some of these conversations My
Hope Is that this sort of annihilates
the believe all women narrative that
we've been subjecting ourselves to
because it's just inherently untrue you
can't look at a group of people and
because of their gender say that they're
meant to be believed and yeah I hope
that that's what happens I I think the
unfortunate side of this is now that you
have a lot of actual female victims of
domestic abuse who are not going to be
believed in the the wake of what she's
done so there's a lot of different sides
to this
yeah it was weird to see something
like a trial like that online although I
think it was probably appropriate I know
there were people commenting saying this
should have been kind of behind closed
doors but the fact that Johnny Depp's
career was actually completely sabotaged
it was like no maybe people do deserve
to kind of see this given the fact he
was like the star and then disappeared
yeah I had that same conversation like
is this okay is this a reflection of a
healthy Society yeah yeah basically but
then I thought about it and I was like
well she's the one who brought this
whole story to the Press she made this a
worldwide yeah yeah and it deserves to
be uh reconciled as a worldwide
announcement if that's what you came to
the table with so that's the thing
that's Justified it for me but I still
feel that same creepy feeling about just
watching people display all the intimate
ins and outs of their relationship
it is it's weird I don't know why that
was allowed I might have to look into
that there must have been a reason that
it was actually televised because that's
that's do you know why it was actually
televised and I I tried looking into it
too like did they have to consent to it
being televised and if so is that
another incentive for all of this and
yeah it's just it's a sticky situation
because it's just this mix of just
celebrity and fame and salacious stories
and all this stuff and I I've been
watching Russell Brand a lot lately and
he's been he's been commenting on it and
saying oh he's fantastic like I've I've
been obsessed with him for a while but
even more so now with with his views and
how he communicates these things but his
view has just been the same like this is
a really strange thing for us all to be
going through but also brings up
discussions that need to be had so is
that the trade-off that we have here
yeah yeah fair enough uh did you get did
you get banned on tick tock I've been
banned so many times on that live uh so
I the main marker that I get on that
platform is hate speech so if if you go
and say that men or men and women are
women it's hate speech if I go and say
well I'm a black person who doesn't
particularly agree with the idea of
systemic racism hate speech taken down
and I get permanently bad I think I've
been permanently banned three or four
times now uh and then they always give
me my account back
wow is that the do you think that's the
most left-wing platform out there right
now
honestly I think so uh we could go
through and look at everything but Tick
Tock is truly I've never seen something
more sensitive to saying something
outside of the box or that is not widely
accepted by that ideology and I have
just never seen more young people so
confidently espousing what is really
radical ideology and millions and
millions of likes hundreds of thousands
of comments and it's it's just sold to
you it's it's insane and that's what's
made me start making videos in the
beginning I just hopped on Tick Tock
just to see what it was because
everybody was talking about it and then
Trump did that whole CCP thing so I was
like yeah let's look at this and I went
on my for you page for what they curated
for me and it was all this stuff about
just like racism and sell your body and
grooming and and uh you know sexual
empowerment and all this stuff and I
thought this is insane this is
unbelievable
wow mine was strange at the beginning
too I haven't been on it very much but I
remember at the beginning I was like
whoa that didn't get me right if that's
like the average consumer that they
didn't get me right at all no but then
then I'm thinking okay well they know
that their platform is widely used by
people who are like 13 to 18 and those
people are impressionable and might not
have uh direct distinct opinions yet and
if you see just all these other young
people saying the same thing you're like
oh well everybody literally everybody on
Tick Tock says that this is true so this
is what I believe now it's crazy yikes
yeah that's concerning
okay
um
how much sex edit should schools have
this is something that I struggled with
uh just thinking about I tried to
remember when I started getting sex
education in school and I don't think it
was until about fifth grade and I don't
remember how old yeah same for you I
think I think mine was fifth grade too
and I think you're about 11 10 or 11. I
think okay 10 or 11. and I just remember
learning that you know if you're gonna
have sex you should use a condom and you
should get STD checked and and just the
very basic simple this is how a baby is
made so watch out and I don't think
there's anything in inherently wrong
with that I think if you approach the
subject with just here's what is
objectively true about making this
decision in your life and here are the
things that could happen that's totally
fine uh I think where we got into like
the whole don't say gay Bill and all of
this stuff is going farther uh outside
the the span of neutrality and talking
about things like gender and the
different sexual experiences you can
have and you know I don't want to get
too did you get that did you get that in
school
no not at all there was no discussion of
you could possibly uh feel dysmorphic
from whatever body you were born in
around eating like eating disorders and
things like that we would talk about
that sort of uh dysmorphia but nothing
in relation to gender we never got that
we never got like these are the
different sex acts that you could
perform with somebody which is
screenshots that I'm seeing right now
from a lot of like Elementary School
Middle School age kids so that's where I
sort of draw the line just talk about
what is objectively true and I would
even say you can talk about the fact
that some people choose to do that with
the same sex totally fine and here are
the things that you need to do if that's
your choice totally fine but we don't
need to do all that other stuff
let the parents handle it
yeah yeah let the parents handle it um
how do you feel so this is something I
kind of shied a topic I shied away from
for a while because Dad was all
um wrapped up with Bill c-16 and you
know compelled speech he was very well
he's still against compelled speech and
it kind of got wrapped up in the trans
debate that's a debate
um and so I kind of avoided it but then
recently seeing especially in college
sports seeing these people that are like
biological males especially the swimmer
this really pissed me off because it was
like you know six foot I don't know
three like giant man competing with like
women and
it just boggles my mind and it feels
regressive like like women had a lot to
fight for for a long time to be taken
seriously to be able to work in the
workplace even to go to university in
the first place and then to have oh the
people winning in women's sports or
biological men but don't worry it's fair
it's just too far
um what's your opinion on on how that's
been going I mean I completely agree
with everything you just said and I I
like to approach people who disagree
with me with a high degree of empathy
because I was there before in my life
but when you when you watch things like
this happen and you see how devoid they
are of logic and just actually being
having Integrity when it comes to
talking about these things it makes me
upset to see it and that's swimmer that
you're talking about in particular Leah
Thomas just one on Good Morning America
to talk about uh I don't know what
pronouns to use their experience uh
being a part of this this swim team and
said you know I know a lot of people are
upset about this but I'm happy and this
idea that an individual's happiness is
above fairness is above infringing on
other people's rights is above
infringing on like the careers that
these young women have worked their
entire lives for unbelievable to me that
anybody could see it and then you know
if you're gonna approach it in good
faith and go yeah I recognize the
biological Advantage but I still think
it's okay that's a different discussion
but there are people coming to the table
and saying well there's no Advantage
there the body is not different it's the
exact same you know cisgendered women
are different too and there's a lot of
variation so it doesn't matter and when
you start being disingenuous that's when
I'm like okay we need to we need to
knock this out and I'm sure you can
speak to this you're accepting of people
who are adults and are are transgender
and want to change their bodies is that
something that you're you're cool with
if they're adults right if you're adults
I don't really care like do what you
want as long as it's not going to be
kind of put on me yeah
and that's why we're we've sort of been
forced to get into this discussion about
it because we agree on that and I think
that's something that your your dad
agreed with when he was talking about
the c-16 bill and all this stuff too and
suddenly they're like okay not only is
it okay but we need to we can step on
female athletes and we can compel your
speech and we can force you to accept
this reality too and that's where we go
whoa whoa whoa wait a minute I said it
was cool just don't come and step on my
right and my lifestyle please
yeah yeah yeah yeah pretty crazy
situation this episode is sponsored by
nordvpn if you follow the show for a
while then you probably already know how
important it is for me to make sure I
can access American Netflix anywhere in
the world there isn't any country that's
stopping me from watching my shows they
can try but they won't succeed that's
the main benefit of nordvpn I think but
they also use state-of-the-art
encryption that keeps you safe from
third parties who want to watch your
online activity they also protect you
from hackers malware and other malicious
threats online VPN stands for virtual
private Network
using nordvpn's encrypted connection is
an easy and effective way to reclaim
your online privacy and know that your
data is safe plus watch online content
anywhere with over 5300 servers around
the world nordvpn never buffers or
crashes there are huge number of servers
translates to connection speeds of up to
6730 megabits per second grab your
nordvpn deal today over at nordvpn.com
tmpp or use promo code tmpp for 61 off
their Premium plan and their free
anti-malware feature all with nordvpn's
30-day money-back guarantee enjoy the
rest of this episode
what do you think about Biden's idea to
Pardon student debt
I don't think it's going to happen at
least not in the scale that it was
promised to a lot of young people a lot
of times when I see this I just think
it's a political ploy to get young
people out to to vote and to support you
and it seems to work every time when
you're a young person facing the idea of
higher education and you see how
expensive it is yeah and you hear this
side go I'm going to totally take care
of that for you that's the side I'm
going to go to her because that's that's
the one that affects my life so I think
it's a ploy in some ways he might
forgive maybe like ten thousand dollars
debt from people how much is that
actually going to do but just from uh a
fairness standpoint you chose to take
out that loan you chose to pursue higher
education nobody forced you to to put
yourself in in this insurmountable debt
so why is it now the government's
obligation to take you out of that are
we going to do the same for people who
regret taking out a mortgage on their
house or regret taking out that car loan
it's essentially the same thing money
giving being given to you in order to
pursue something uh and there's
certainly an issue with how expensive
higher education is and I think that's a
discussion we should all be having but
it's not the discussion of forgiving
debt that people willingly put
themselves in
what did you do for University
so I when I left High School I started
working for that organization I did that
for a year and decided not to pursue
college and then after that I left and I
was like no more politics I'm not
talking about this anymore what's
something that I can do that's pretty
pretty cut and dry and I was like
medicine I won't get into arguments
about politics or religion or anything
in medicine yeah but now go into the
Sciences yeah exactly exactly so I
actually started working at an
Immunology Clinic which is why you know
when you said you had an immune disorder
I was like oh yeah I totally get the the
turmoil that you probably went through
so I started working there and working
with patients and at night I was going
to school for nursing uh eventually with
the with the intent of becoming a
midwife but that obviously didn't pan
out so here I am yeah no fair I went
back to school for Sciences too I took
two two years of Sciences it was just
really interesting like it's hard and
it's similar to the Nursing degree with
just the and the first couple years of
that it's intense it's much easier than
an arts degree oh it is here's a
textbook to memorize like okay yeah
here's every part in the body and you
need to know exactly how it works and
what medications to give and all that
but it's so it's so interesting and so
fun and once you have the information
it's so useful I would come to find that
medicine is actually just as contentious
as politics which I'm sure you learned
too in your own health Journey but uh it
was still it was still a great a great
couple years there yeah and then how
come you decided to not pursue that do
you just the opportunity elsewhere yeah
I got that call from prageru and they
said yeah you know uh let's let's move
you out here to LA and you can pursue
this and I thought yeah I I think it's
an important thing to be doing right now
I'll take that up and luckily I got out
right in the nick of time because it was
just before they started saying you know
if you're going to be a nurse you have
to be vaccinated and you have to do this
this and that so I got out just before
like the authoritarian measures started
taking place
yeah yikes okay well I think that was a
good decision I mean yeah um absolutely
yeah yeah no no not at all for that
reason for sure but also if the purpose
of pursuing an education is to get a job
and then you already have an opportunity
for a job I think right I think um
people in college make that mistake
sometimes if they're presented with an
opportunity and they're like well I have
to finish my degree it's like yeah but
is the opportunity what you're working
for anyway or what you're working
towards it's like maybe maybe it's more
important than the degree exactly and I
go back and think about just my time in
K-12 school and how we were constantly
inundated with this idea that you have
to go to college like when I told
guidance counselors at my school like I
don't think I'm gonna go to college they
were so upset they were blowing through
the roof like they could not believe
that a young person would not want to go
to college and now I get on the other
side of it I'm just like wow this feels
like this just massive Ponzi scheme to
get all of our money when we could be
pursuing Avenues elsewhere all the the
people that I meet in this line of work
and I talk to him just like what college
did you go to oh well I went here for a
couple years and I dropped out and now
I'm doing this or I didn't go to college
at all and so many successful people uh
didn't do that and didn't didn't fall
for that of course if your career needs
higher education by all means pursue it
and I think it's a wonderful thing but
it's a it is a big trick in a lot of
ways
yeah I think it I think it works for
some people who need a more structured
way to learn like maybe in order to
learn you have to take classes and you
have to be told what to read and you
have to be forced to write essays but if
you can go online and take courses or if
you read by yourself then it's kind of a
giant waste of money like you said
especially in America like at least
Canada is more reasonable but America
like it's a crazy amount of money and
then what do you get exactly
yeah you get debt and a cookie cutter
education that everybody else around you
got and I I would love to see education
change to be more personalized to
students and I hope that's something
that we're on the the cusp of but it
doesn't really look like it
I think the system is going to have to
break completely it's
okay you see yeah we'll agree Wills like
abolish the public schools I'm not quite
on that train yet I think uh I think we
just need a push from from parents to
just have personalized education when I
was at the end of my schooling career
that's when they started started talking
about you know if you have certain
interests will sort of cater your
education to those interests I don't
know if they're continuing to do that
but I wish they would I know a lot of
schools in Europe when you're like 16
and you're like I'm interested in being
a mechanic they're like okay perfect
we'll go and teach you how to do that or
I'm interested in in English okay we'll
we'll put you down that path I wish we
did that more here and I don't know why
we don't do that
yeah I think you'd have to go to a
pretty expensive private school to get
that kind of education and even then
they push you towards College
it might just be outdated like maybe
maybe 15 20 years ago that was the way
to go right maybe the education you got
in college was the way to go maybe it
wasn't as expensive and for a number of
reasons and maybe the public school
system or private school system just
hasn't caught up and they're like oh
wait College isn't what you think it is
anymore exactly and our world is opening
up to so many different new jobs and
careers yeah it never existed before
yeah and we haven't accommodated for
that yet I don't think no not at all not
at all even using social media as a type
of job is like oh yeah four years ago
five years ago even now but especially
five years ago it was like that's a joke
like let's kind of look down on it was
like no no this is serious There's an
opportunity here yeah and now with Tick
Tock it's like 15 year olds are
providing for their entire family just
by making videos every single day how do
you how do you make money off of tick
tock do they get ad sponsorships so
there's a mult there's multiple things
that you can do so you can become a
Creator and once you reach uh a certain
amount of followers and views on your
videos you get invited to a tick tock
Creator fund which is a very poorly run
uh monetization tool that they have
where they have one big pool of money
and all the creators are added in and as
your videos get more views you get more
money but that pool of money never
changes it's it's finite for some reason
and then they have the Creator
marketplace where you can link up with
Brands and and do ads through your Tick
Tock videos and get clothing lines and
all that fun stuff okay so there's so
many ways to to make money off of tick
tock wow
yeah
I have to learn that platform more it's
really really useful I think it's yeah I
mean at your at your own risk it's I
think it's one of the fastest growing
social media platforms where that has
really given an opportunity for anybody
and I mean anybody to make a name for
their self whether that's a good thing
super questionable but super super
useful if you're already doing it and
it's something that you're good at which
obviously you are
thank you I'm just taking podcast Clips
I'm like good luck Tick Tock here's some
podcast Clips not sure exactly if that's
the type of content you're into but this
is what you get I get your stuff on my
for you page so it must be working good
ha infiltrating
that's what I want
okay this is this is fun
um what do you think women want in men
exactly the opposite of what they're
saying they want right now
honestly I there's a there seems to be a
culture of women saying you know I want
this absolutely perfect Prince Charming
who dotes on me all the time and is
super emotional and is constantly
updating me on his feelings and then
they show their boyfriend and it's like
this masculine provider protector who is
you know constantly there for you but
handles problems so I think that's what
women actually want and what they
gravitate towards but what comes out of
the mouth can be a little different I
think men I don't know if you've noticed
but they're a lot more feminine these
days at least here in La where I live a
lot of very feminine men but I think
women typically look for
an amount of masculinity that usurps
their own so whatever that might be for
you
that I like that explanation I did um I
had a conversation the other day and I
don't know whether or not this is true
but apparently uh this is getting it
into the conspiracy part of my show
which I extremely enjoy and I love it
who knows what out what out there is
writing final hat on oh yeah um I don't
even know how tin foil this is but
apparently there's a lot of Chinese
production companies that are backing
Hollywood movies that are portraying
more feminine men and so they'll push a
whole bunch of money into these movies
saying oh no this is the ideal man just
like feminine man is the ideal man but
they won't show that content in China so
we're just brainwashing all the young
people being like Oh no like I want when
I grow up I want to marry a pansy that's
like right now you don't right but
isn't that crazy it is crazy and I I've
seen the same thing like they'll they'll
fund like feminist campaigns here in the
United States that talk about toxic
masculinity and feminizing men and they
funded CRT videos like it's shown in
American schools but they would never
show that in China which is crazy
unbelievable it seems to me like they
are just slowly chipping away at us
through the own our own divides that
we've created and they're just fueling
them and sparking them even more and
with the men with the man one you have
to think that's like long-term chess
move yeah insane like we have now a
culture of feminine men who are linking
up with masculine women because women
are getting more masculine in our in our
nation and then they're going to create
even more feminized boys and more and
more and more and long-term big win for
China there
okay yeah I feel that yeah what a chess
move though like decades ago they're
like sitting around some evil table
being like you know it'd be funny
turning all the men into women in
America that would be funny let's just
do this slowly yeah it'd be funny while
we become like this Global sensation and
push for this globalist economy and
everything at the same time it's really
just like long-term decades-long chess
moves of of that old adage if you know I
don't need to destroy my enemy I'll have
them do it themselves and I think that's
honestly where we're headed
yeah pretty crazy well it's good that
places like pragger you exist just to
give kind of a voice and it's nice that
you've been brought on and they're
they're trying to work with younger
people too because a lot of the
conservative movement is kind of like
well what it's stereotyped as which is
like old middle-aged white men talking
about boring things yeah which which
isn't the case at all so no that was my
view of conservatives it's just like
their old crotchety men capitalists who
don't care about anything that you feel
and never want to hear you speak and all
this stuff and I I think I ended up
finding Thomas soul and he broke through
that idea for me oh yeah he's he's just
like a strong hitter I feel like anybody
who comes across these videos has their
mind changed and he's in his 90s now
which is just crazy and I wonder what I
know like who's gonna take on that
massive Legacy and and push for forth
that message but yeah I had the same
view so now I'm like totally trying to
break through that stereotype and play
conservatives are fun they care about
you they're empathetic to the way that
you feel even though they tell you that
you're that you're wrong and just break
the perception just break the perception
I like that they're compassionate to the
way that you feel even though they'll
tell you that you're wrong I like that
yeah that's where I'm at because I I
stepped into this and I saw a lot of
conservatives I'm sure you see this too
who are like I'm a lion you're a sheep
you're so wrong you got brainwashed that
would never happen to me you're so
stupid and I thought if I was a leftist
which I was I would have watched that
video for like two seconds and turned it
off how can I approach this in a way
that keeps them and when I get protested
and or people leave hate comments on my
stuff I go hey yo I used to be just like
you four years ago I would have been
leaving this same exact comment and I
totally understand why you feel the way
that you feel why you support the
policies that you pers you support can I
give you a different perspective that
might change your mind and that has
seemed to break down some of the
barriers of people who at the outset
would have never talked to me in a
million years
oh that's fantastic that's fantastic so
have you experienced a lot of negativity
online and does it bother you
it does not bother me but I experience
so much of it uh I when I first started
doing this I thought you know I'd get a
big wave of hate and then it would
slowly die out but it's just a constant
ever flowing pool of hate of just you're
a race Trader you're a [ __ ] you're an
Uncle Tom I can't believe you hate
yourself you must have been raised by a
white woman not even knowing that my mom
is just like a super leftist
um and it doesn't bother me at all
because it's exactly who I was as a
person so I totally understand the space
that people are coming from in saying
those things I did a recent I'm sure
you've like stepped into controversy at
it at some point and just been like whoa
this is a huge flow of hate that I
didn't anticipate I yeah I called out
this tick tocker not really called out I
did a really respectful podcast about
transgender ideology and talking about
people on Tick Tock who are getting
famous for being trans to the tune of
just millions and millions of followers
and talking about whether or not it was
the sign of a healthy Society even
respected the person's pronouns during
the podcast and death threat after death
threat after death threat people were
trying to dox me and find my email and
all this stuff and it was unbelievable
but I I just can't imagine being a young
person who's not ready to take that on
and how scared people are to come out
about what they think how would you
define political correctness
I even struggle with the phrase itself
because it implies that something is
correct about what you're doing uh
political correctness for me is just I
think one side of the aisle right now
dictating what language is acceptable
for use and what language isn't and
people choosing to subscribe to that and
calling themselves politically correct I
think the the phrase inherently has this
air of just virtue signal I am
politically correct I get to Pat myself
on the back from for this but really
it's just handcuffing the dialogue that
we're allowed to have and when you
handcuff dialogue like that you are
cutting off an Avenue to finding out
what is true and what is right so
political correctness is probably one of
the worst things that's happened to
political discussions
do you have advice for people who are
stuck in a an echo chamber that they
don't want to be part of
if you don't want to be part of it
listen to that voice and I imagine
something that keeps you in the Echo
chamber is a fear of stepping outside of
it and a fear of how the people who have
surrounded you for so long will react to
you stepping outside of it but when you
do so you will find so much support just
for simply simply questioning where you
are and I think one of the most
fulfilling and relieving things I've
ever come to think in my life is that I
know absolutely nothing and what I'm
talking about and telling people about
on a on a daily in my projects is just
what I feel right now and what I think
right now and having that be constantly
subject to change is going to take your
life in so many different directions
that you never would have even thought
about before when you were in the Echo
chamber it's honestly the most freeing
experience you can possibly put yourself
through even though it's scary so I
would say step over the fear for a
little bit and pursue it and see what
happens
I love it that was great that was great
so what are your goals for your show
where do you see it happening what are
you trying to do
I'm trying to create something that even
though it's under this Prairie umbrella
which I think people hear the word
prayer you and they've automatically
come come up with what they think is
going to be said that I want to give
voice to everybody who comes to the
table about these issues I constantly
want to be butting heads of people who
disagree with me and if I'm wrong about
something come there and tell me that
I'm wrong because I would love to be
proved wrong I would love to find more
truth I would love to find a perspective
that I didn't have so I hope to make
this show something that is not just you
know tap dancing for the side that tends
to agree with you the most but is
something where people can hop in and
have discussions in the chat about how
they feel and go back and forth with
this intent of finding out what is right
and what is the best way to live that is
really my goal and I always say you know
if all these social issues that I talk
about get solved tomorrow I'll take off
my hat and put it away the mic goes off
and I'm done I'm gonna to go back to
Leading my normal life but as long as
they persist I feel like people like you
and me have something to bring to the
conversation and it's it's always a a
good time and it's very fulfilling
you're a lovely individual oh thank you
thank you yeah so much no this has been
fun
um if people aren't following you online
where can they go to find you you can
type in my killer name amla epinobi I
know it's a tough one to type out but on
any platform you'll find me under that
name you can also follow and support
prageru because they're the ones who
support me and allow me to get my
message out there and talk about the
things that I talk about with such
Freedom so that's where you can find me
anywhere and everywhere
okay we're gonna link those below so
people just press on it I get it I get
having a difficult to spell name
you win you win with a difficulty spell
name but Kayla I get the weirdest you
must get it I get the weirdest like like
it's just like someone just put their
fingers on the keyboard it's like that
was that's not it but yeah no yours
yours might be just with your iteration
of Michaela it might be just as rough as
mine honestly I must I was thinking
about how to spell your name this
morning and I was like I don't know
exactly yeah spell our name okay
that's pretty funny okay okay Amala
thank you very much for coming on and
we'll link all your socials below this
was fun thank you for having me I really
appreciate it it's been great